we are particularly pleased that Tata
Consultancy Services has chosen Carnegie
Mellon University as its first major and
largest university partner as they do
pioneering work at the cutting edge of
technology essentially around the world
the TCS engagement with Carnegie Mellon
University symbolizes something much
grander than dollars and cents or
collaborations Carnegie Mellon as a
global University can play a significant
role in taking its challenge outside of
Pittsburgh when we thought about the
possibilities for us its it was
important to have a very strong
university partnership with a school
which brings an enormous capability and
in this world partnerships are very
critical so I am very very happy and
proud that we have this wonderful
partnership developing between TCS and
Carnegie Mellon Chandra and I we met in
China in Tianjin at the summer Davos at
the World Economic Forum Carnegie Mellon
is known for the best of Education
investors research the researchers here
the institution will give a great
opportunity for TCS researchers to do
some joint programs which will solve not
only the industry problems but create
breakthroughs in solving some of the
societal problems today we are here to
announce a major gift to Carnegie Mellon
University the thirty-five million
dollar gift from Tata Consultancy
Services
it's the largest corporate gift in the
history of Carnegie Mellon University
it's the largest gift from outside the
United States and it's the fifth largest
gift in the history of Carnegie Mellon
you know
in the building
we have TCS obviously and the important
and Pretoria activities that they
represent all of that learning and
academics and experimentations on
display we've worked hard to make this
building contribute in a positive way to
the environment the orientation of the
building the way that the building that
creates solar shading for itself use of
advanced technologies and triple glazing
and things like that that help the
building be a positive influence this
gift will enable Carnegie Mellon
University to create state-of-the-art
facilities where faculty and students
will be able to do cutting-edge research
it will become part and parcel of what
we call a corridor where innovation and
creativity along Forbes Avenue will
flourish
[Music]
you